من المقرر أن يحضر محامو الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب ووزارة العدل
المحكمة بعد ظهر هذا اليوم ، تدور جلسة الاستماع
حول ما إذا كان يجب على سيد خاص
مراجعة الوثائق التي تم الاستيلاء عليها من مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي من
ترامب منزل ترامب كرر
طلبه للحصول على واحدة في ملف الليلة الماضية ،
كل شيء عن الملف غريب
لا يتطرق ملف ترامب إلى
مزاعم العرقلة التي قدمتها
الدوج الذي أخبرت الرئيس بذلك عندما
عملت معه في المكتب البيضاوي ،
نادرًا ما يكون الفعل الأصلي هو الذي يتسبب في وقوع
الناس في المشاكل ، إنه
محاولات عرقلة أو التستر على الحقيقة.
يوضح ملف ترامب قضيته
لتعيينه الرئيسي الخاص ، حيث
تدور الحجج الرئيسية الخاصة حول
امتياز المحامي والموكل ، لكنهم يحاولون بطريقة
خرقاء للغاية جعلهم متحالفين مع
وضع امتياز تنفيذي في ملفه
الرابح يبدو أنه يقر بأن
المستندات التي تم الاستيلاء عليها من قبل مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي تم تمييزها بأنها سرية
ولكنه  قد أكد أنه كان ينبغي
توقعه في السجلات الرئاسية
بأن الإجراء موجود فيه
من الجدير بالملاحظة أن المحفوظات التي تنتمي إليها هي أيضًا التي
خضعت بالفعل
للوثائق التي تطلب سيدًا خاصًا
الآن يمكن أن تكون تكتيكًا للمماطلة وفقًا
لهذا الخبير ، وأعتقد أن هذه الوثيقة تُظهر
أنه لم يكن لديهم وقت
لمواجهة ما الحكومة والتعامل معه حقًا
أمامها لائحة اتهام ، أنا آمي
كيلي أبلغك